a massive tornado packing winds as high
as 130 miles per hour carved straight
through Glen Allen in rural Southeastern
Missouri at least five people were
killed you hear a bunch of wind just
like a train coming Keith and Shannon
Lincoln were home when the Twister hit I
had a carport back there it's gone and
then our detached garage which it took I
think it took the most damage they rode
out the storm in their bathroom where
they prayed they'd be spared how do you
say we're well blessed we got very lucky
lucky they survived when others didn't
we lost some good neighbors down the
road and the whole family this deadly
storm came just a few days after dozens
of Twisters upended communities from
Iowa to Delaware killing at least 33
people Louisville Kentucky is the latest
scene of Devastation yesterday an ef-1
tornado tore through ripping the roof
off this apartment complex